thursday edition of pft ot the extra
show beyond pft live where we delve into
some topics we didn't get to or things
we would like to talk about a little bit
more now this is one that i got a chance
to talk about but shireen didn't because
we had some technical difficulties at
the top of the show the injury to nick
bosa and one of the concerns about the
boso brothers is durability we've seen
plenty of injuries and there's been a
red flag with nick boson some people
think maybe they should have taken quinn
and williams instead of nick boson with
the second overall pick but he's injured
again he may not play in the preseason
he's got an ankle problem on the same
day cornerback jason fred a guy they
really like has an ankle issue as well
and shireen i i just feel like there's
something up with these 49ers where
at a certain point it's not luck at a
certain point there's something that
you're not doing properly to get you
guys ready to play week in and week out
to keep them healthy you see guys get
pretzeled and twisted all the time and
all sorts of angles and positions and
they get up and they're fine and i
really do think there are fundamental
differences between facilities training
staffs medical staffs rehab processes
that allow some teams to keep their guys
healthy and for other teams it's not a
cluster of bad luck it's it's a
different type of cluster altogether
that causes these players to constantly
be injured and if i'm a 49ers fan i'm
getting concerned that there's some
fundamental issue there that is keeping
these guys from being healthy all the
time
well the 49ers certainly have had their
share of injuries no question about that
but so is nick bosa he just can't seem
to stay healthy of course played only
three games last season and and i really
thought he needed to play in the
preseason because of that now his
brother joey bo so we know had to hold
out as a rookie and didn't play and came
in was great when he went once he came
in in the regular season uh but nick
bosa didn't play enough last year and
hadn't played enough in college i don't
think that he needed the reps and in the
preseason but whatever the 49ers problem
is
they have had an awful lot of injuries
more than their share of injuries and
and at some point i think you start
looking at things and evaluating uh to
see why all of these injuries are
happening and if there's anything you
can do better to prevent them
remember when joey bosa showed up after
his hold out he had a hamstring problem
missed his first four games of the
season went on to be the defensive
rookie of the year so that injury issue
has been there for the bosus and it
continues to be there for the 49ers and
as as we get closer and closer to the
regular season and into the regular
season that's when that that optimism
and that hope starts to pop for some of
these teams and for the 49ers it feels
like
each of the last two years and going
into now a third year you just you're
just bracing for that injury that's
going to fundamentally alter the fate of
the franchise and and really it is
injuries i don't want to jinx anybody
but that really is the thing that
determines who can survive every year
there's a team that that had
minimal numbers of players that land on
injured reserve and you see that that
team ends up making it to the playoffs i
mean you get and a lot of it is luck
shireen but i really do believe a lot of
it is having the right procedures in
place to get you guys healthy keep your
guys healthy and allow them to survive
moments on the field that for players on
other teams end up in an injury
well and to me that's why we go back to
two years ago and when we start
reviewing them in history the eagles are
going to go down as one of the greatest
teams in nfl history because of what
they overcame to get there and win it i
mean a backup quarterback winning a
super bowl yes we've seen that some
before
but they lost their left tackle jason
peters they lost jordan hicks they just
had an insurmountable number of injuries
and yet somehow they overcame all of
that and still won the super bowl it
just doesn't happen and they're one of
the rare teams that was able to do it
which speaks to how good they were from
top to bottom that year
yeah and depth is critical in a salary
capped environment the money that you
keep behind to pay for guys who can come
in and play at a high level when there
are injuries and you know they're
inevitable those teams are going to be
best suited to surviving those ups and
downs that inevitably occur when
injuries happen all right in tampa
interceptions inevitably happen for
jameis winston and he's a guy serene
that i've always viewed as someone who
tries to do a little bit more than he
physically can do he tries to will
himself into greatness he tries to will
his team into greatness and that can
lead some awkward moments like the ew
pregame speech from a couple of years
ago but as gm jason light tells siriusxm
nfl radio that he sees a calmer jameis
winston this year a guy who isn't a
rah-rah type a guy who is going about
his business with a demeanor of someone
who expects to win expects to not make
mistakes and expects the team to be
better than it's been
i don't know that that's going to make a
bit of difference for the tampa bay
buccaneers but
we've seen the first four years with
jameis winston something hasn't been
right there and if the influence of
bruce arians
in part includes getting jameis winston
to just kind of calm it down
take it slow
exude
the the right mindset
of a quarterback where there's an
expectation where you don't have to yell
you don't have to do goofy things you
don't have to eat a w you don't have to
make your teammates look at each other
thinking what's wrong with this guy and
it's all in how you carry yourself and
maybe that will make a difference maybe
that's just part of what transforms
jameis winston into the quarterback the
buccaneers have always hoped he was
going to be
you know during the show we talked about
who's going to throw the most
interceptions in the league this year
neither one of us picked jameis winston
and the reason i didn't pick jameis
winston and you hit on it is bruce
arians i just think he can get more out
of jameis winston than what we've seen
in the nfl and i go back to what a good
quarterback jameis winston was in
college under jimbo fisher and i talked
to jimbo fisher uh yesterday but he got
the most out of jameis winston and you
expect bruce sirians to get the most out
of jameis winston in the nfl now what is
the most that jameis whisson has in the
nfl i think we're going to find out this
year it's a very important year
obviously for jameis winston because if
he doesn't get it done he's going to be
looking for a new employer after this
year so being calmer i think is going to
help him and i think bruce arians is
going to help him with that confidence
and staying calmer out there on the
football field and i think there's going
to be fewer interceptions this year and
on the issue of winston possibly leading
the league in interceptions one of the
reasons i don't think he will is i think
that bruce arians will turn him and say
get your ass on the bench halfway
through the season if jameis winston is
continuing to do the things that ariens
doesn't want him to do and i don't think
aryans would hesitate if he thinks it's
necessary to bench jameis winston and go
with someone else that's what he will do
regardless of who the quarterback is in
tampa receiver mike evans one of the
very best in the national football
league and he's very soft-spoken he's
very quiet a texas a m great who came
into the league with johnny manziel and
i remember guys like jim rome
criticizing him because he's not a good
interview well you know what he's he he
just doesn't have much to say it's on us
to draw it out of him but now he's got
something to say and he says it would be
a major disappointment if the buccaneers
aren't better this year than what
they've been during his time in the nfl
i mean this is a team that hasn't been
in the playoffs since 2007 and they
haven't even been a serious contender
they had one year in 2016 where they
were kind of putting it together they
had that winning streak they lost to the
cowboys in dallas on a sunday night and
that kind of ended it but mike evans a
guy who says very little coming out and
saying it will be a major disappointment
if the buccaneers don't make it this
year
that's one of the things that has kind
of drawn me to the buccaneers as a team
that i'm just keeping an eye on them
because i i love bruce arians
and i'm i love a great story and it
would be fascinating if he could go to
tampa and turn this thing around
you know i talked earlier about deandre
hopkins kind of being under the radar
when we start naming top receivers in
this league and it's because he's not as
outspoken too probably but you do that
with mike evans and you forget about him
when you start naming the top receivers
in league as a guy who produces a
thousand yards year after year after
year and maybe should have been the
heisman trophy winner at a m that year
because he made johnny look great he
made so many great catches
and has been just as good in the nfl but
he's played on some bad teams they've
had one winning record since he's been
there and i know he wants more and so
when he speaks he's quiet i don't think
he's a bad interview because i've had
some great interviews with him when he
speaks he says a lot but he's very quiet
very soft-spoken and he doesn't say a
whole lot
unless you pull it out of him but when
he does speak like he did
in this interview saying i'm going to be
disappointed if we don't get done what i
think we can do then you know that he
thinks they've got a pretty good
football team and thinks they can win
this year
the key to interviewing mike evans is
you always better have your next
question ready because you're going to
have to ask it sooner than you ever
imagined because he's not going to give
you a very long answer and if it calls
for a yes or no
you're not getting you're not getting
yes or no in an explanation you're
getting yes or no and then he just waits
for the next question but look at the
career this guy's had five nfl seasons 6
100 receiving yards 40 touchdowns and he
had a career high in 2018 with
1524 receiving yards on 86 catches for a
17.7 yard average that was a career high
as well and yeah it's just like
nobody pays attention to mike evans well
you know what if they thrive this year
he's one of the first names that we're
going to be mentioning when we talk
about the tampa bay buccaneers when we
talk about the buffalo bills one of the
first names we mentioned is sean mccoy
in large part because they don't have a
lot of other star players as we
mentioned as when we were doing our
rundown of the various games to be
played tonight week one of the
pre-season lesean mccoy did not have a
big year in 2018 for the bills he played
in 14 games he barely had over 500 yards
averaged 3.2 yards per carry and he's
got a big salary for 2019 and there's
been some suggestion that maybe just
maybe he would be cut that hasn't
happened but sharing i've seen this time
and again where a team will go to a
player at a time when there's there's no
other option out there in free agency
the rosters are set elsewhere and that's
when you squeeze the guy and it's a very
reasonable case look we just can't
justify six and a half million dollars
this year we we want to pay you three
and a half million we want the rest to
be in incentives or something like that
but i i think lesean mccoy should be
bracing
for
something between now and labor day
weekend where the bills come to him and
suggest that he redo his deal and take
less money or else they're going to go
with the other guys they have and they
have plenty of other guys at running
back this year led by future hall of
famer frank gore
now normally you don't see the preseason
as big for veterans but for lesean mccoy
i do think it's big i think he needs to
show him something he's going to start
in that week two preseason game and i
think he needs to play well and you know
a lot depends on how frank gore looks
tonight too if frank gore looks terrific
i mean why wouldn't you move on from
lashon mccoy and say you know we've got
enough running backs here that that we
can make it happen i i do think if they
have lashon mccoy and frank gore i think
they have two of the best running backs
in the nfl i think you can compare it
obviously to the browns when kareem hunt
comes back uh but i do think that they
they will be terrific at that running
back position it will take a load off of
their young quarterback that they can be
able to hand off the ball and throw some
short passes to those guys and and make
that happen
well and they really love devin
singletary their rookie third rounder
who is the third stringer behind lesean
mccoy and frank gore and tj yelton
floating around on the roster as well so
they have a very very
good and deep running back class and
that just makes it look at some point
and it it happens to every player at
some point it doesn't matter what you've
done
it only matters what they think you're
going to do tomorrow and how much
they're willing to pay you for it and
and i think that his salary is out of
whack in comparison to his production
and i i will not be surprised in fact i
i expect that at some point this month
there's going to be an attempt to get
lesean mccoy to redo his his contract
and they may let him save some face with
incentives or whatever but i think that
this that something is going to happen
because it's just it's not they always
talk about the best interest of the team
how can you say it's in the best of the
team to pay him that kind of money when
he gave you 500 yards last year shireen
yeah so what have you done for me lately
league and lately he hasn't been very
good and we don't list him among those
top running backs in the nf i didn't
know if i'd put him in the top 10 really
when you start listing them but he's
certainly not in the top five of running
backs and his salary doesn't match with
the production that we've seen so yeah
it's not going to surprise you if they
do that
would be a possibility if that for a cut
or trade say ezekiel it's not going to
show up for the regular season if you're
the dallas cowboys do you go try to get
lesean mccoy
hey that's even juicier than adrian
peterson and more realistic because
buffalo's not in the division so uh
you know i i continue
to say and believe
that
if the cowboys are serious
about moving on and turning the page
that's the kind of move
that would make me think they're serious
alfred morris does not make me
think that they're serious about it they
make a trade for sean mccoy they try to
get an adrian peterson they look for
another veteran tailback who may be
available as the regular season
approaches that's when i think hey they
are serious about hunkering down here
and not paying ezekiel elliot a new
contract in 2019.
yeah no question about it i know they
like tony pollard he looked good
yesterday in practice they were raving
about him probably going to put a post
on him today but he is a rookie and you
know rookie running back sometimes we
see him do really well with ezekiel
elliott and kareem hunt leading the
league and sometimes we don't and i
think it's a really tough thing to ask a
rookie running back to come in
especially on a team that you feel like
is a super bowl contender to me they
need a veteran running back and i don't
know if alfred morris is the answer
there at that position if they're
looking for a veteran if zeke doesn't
come in
in exactly one month the cowboys will be
hosting the giants to start the 2019
regular season and one of the big
questions looming over the cowboys in
the entire nfl will ezekiel elliott be
there and if not what will they be doing
here's what we're going to be doing
we're going to be shutting up until
tomorrow shireen thank you so much two
straight days for shireen you'll
probably never want to do it again after
dealing with me for two straight days
but but the opportunity will rise again
at some point down the road chris sims
will be back tomorrow check us out
around the clock at profootballtalk.com
everybody have a great thursday we'll
see you here on friday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports